this morning a new installment in our
series a more perfect union
it shows what unites us as a country is
far greater than what divides us today
we look at how music can bridge
differences and feel Souls Army veteran
Joshua Gertz and Nashville music folk
musician Mary Gautier are two Americans
who seem to have nothing in common but
thanks to a powerful experience at a
songwriting retreat there now lifelong
friends and creative collaborators they
spoke with Jan Crawford Jan good morning
well good morning you know we know about
the struggles that some of our returning
War veterans go through as they battle
the devastating effects of PTSD and
although there are a lot of therapy
programs out there only a few use
professional musicians to achieve some
pretty dramatic results one group is
actually turning wounded warriors into
song writers and that is saving lives
one 4-minute song at a time backstage at
Nashville's Grand Ole Opry it's always a
night to remember and this is where Josh
you come in here
[Music]
but for retired Army sergeant Joshua
Gertz it's also a night he never thought
he'd lived to see it's like I won some
kind of like VIP sweepstakes and I get
to just be up there in watch country
music hallowed halls started in
September 2003 when he was finishing up
his tour of duty in Iraq it was my last
night in country roadside bomb went off
right next to my truck
he suffered a traumatic brain and spinal
cord injury but back home with his wife
and two children in upstate New York
the psychological injuries became far
worse I just felt like a burden it was
like I walked in the room it sucked the
life out of that room everyone got quiet
and you thought they would be better off
without you you attempted suicide yeah I
knew when I was going to do it again do
you have a specific date or what was the
date November 7th why was that that's a
day my friend just killed that friend
Army private first class
Thomas Falk died in a car accident a few
years before the bombing the two met in
basic training and were like brothers
his two lifelines a love of the
harmonica and his wife Lisa who enrolled
him in a music program for veterans it's
quite a view it's about a hundred acres
here Darden Smith and Mary Judd
co-founded songwriting with soldiers
just over five years ago they bring
together vets and professional musicians
and retreats like this one in Northern
Virginia
it's not songwriting for soldiers my
song writing about centers my name with
collaboration that is the key the events
are equal parts group therapy writing
workshop and jam sessions the vets
shared their feelings and experiences
the musicians helped craft them into a
song the song is gigantic it's so
powerful and they have it forever
and they see other people hear their
song and they see the other people
tearing up or singing or laughing they
feel like their song is actually serving
other people at his first retreat in
2015 Gertz connected with folk
singer-songwriter Mary Gautier and I
looked out the window as the veterans
were starting to arrive and Lisa and I
just see the pain and I'm looking at my
window and I my first thought was he's
mine I have to write with that guy what
did you see that made you think I want
to suffering it's almost like a red hot
fireball was inside of him and I knew
that the song could take that red hot
fireball and make it tangible and we
could toss it out into the group and it
would not only take some of the
infection out of him but it would give
courage to the group and be useful for
other people your pain is like medicine
for other people I think so and you
never thought of it like that
no no whatever it is if he can have one
another person it's worth it the
newly-formed oooooo talked until the
song became clear there was one
preeminent thing
that really was was bringing him to his
knees and that was the one of the death
of his best friend
I think the first line is kind of where
you're in my trust you know she's trying
to get the story and like I don't know
looking back and what what comes to mind
si uh hell knows
and she good and he wrote down the first
line okay magna
oh hell no that's like it's that easy
yeah that's what I found like this is
kind of cool if the music's right it
acts like a magnet just pulls that story
all of that stuff that I held in and was
so afraid to let have just pour it out
it poured into the song still on the
ride now one of 11 on Boucher's new
album all co-written by songwriting with
soldiers vets and that album bring
skirts here to the stage of the Grand
Ole Opry this is retired Army sergeant
Joshua giris
looking back now who the hell know
[Music]
the soul of a dead soldier go my
guardian angel
maybe it's you
[Music]
the power of songwriting with soldiers
to me is mirrored in the fact that Josh
Kurtz is with us it's the proof right
there that it worked because it's
civilians and military communities
changing
I mean on the surface you could not be
so what does that say that we need to
get the hell away from the surface so
now when I think about my friend I think
about playing the Opry with me and I
think about that smile and my new family
there's
now it's obvious to anyone who
participates these in these retreats
that it works miracles for the veterans
but now two major academic institutions
are preparing to launch scientific
studies on the power of music to help
heal traumatic brain injuries and asked
her Josh Kurtz he is still a part of
songwriting with soldiers but now as a
volunteer Gail Oh Jan I believe I
believe and I'm so glad Josh ghost is
still with us but beautiful music he's
leaving us with and he and Mary together
very nice Thank You Jana very much story
oh boy you'll be celebrating life
November 7th going forward yes yes
cheering him on always you cannot want
to get that album too